what's in about the kennel chef nanny
buddy
[Music]
ah we're gonna have some fun today we're
here with nanny bobby back in studio
along with don hamrick of chapman
automotive the sponsors of today's
segment and we're going to learn about
how we can make a simple and delicious
french omelette that's it it's dawn's
thing but before
yeah before it starts i just want to say
one thing you just opened a brand new
dealership this is a brand new week for
you and so i want to say congratulations
thank you you were quite excited about
it
it's a dodge chrysler jeep and ram store
brand new on our old location at boulder
highway and sahara awesome we had been
there for many many years and it just
was time to get a uh
yeah i think we're going to be just
great oh do you want to show them how to
cut an onion well i am going to do that
but i got to get this thing on the okay
that we're going to do next so let's let
that so we have a don hamrick tidbit not
an annie bubby tidbit
the thing i like to do about dicing and
onion is to to do
a series of cross cuts
and then
you'll turn around um
and then when you actually slice it
you're cutting it off
in diced pieces so i just make these
like that and then i want you to watch
how this turns out kind of as i start to
cut it
see they're all coming out nice yeah
they're all coming out all diced so you
made that look easy too you can take and
and i've managed to do this and keep all
my fingers
i don't want to jinx myself but then if
you see they all come out diced just
like that yeah so you make your cross
cuts very simple and we've already got
the onions because this is tv we got the
onions mushrooms and red peppers browned
up right and then i just want to show
how fabulous these are look at these
produces yes they're fantastic
i mean look at that they're so beautiful
they not so they're so rosy red and
glossy okay what do you want me to use
here this one yeah voila how many eggs
have you put in so far i did two but you
know these are not just regular eggs
because marlon needs to explain to you
yeah so these are if you can um just
look at that kendall it's they're blue
eggs and brown eggs and so what is the
difference we've got more than just
color yeah so what is the difference
between blue eggs brown eggs and white
eggs tell me how do you peel bananas
right
so the difference is absolutely nothing
it's just that white eggs come from a
white chicken
brown eggs come from that brown rooster
looking chicken that we all know and
blue eggs come from a blue chicken and
that's right tastes the same in fact
dawn has
one blue and one brown are these are
these farm fresh eggs they are because
those are there really is such a
difference there is and you're gonna see
so we've got
voila this can be a little veggie omelet
and um
uh the homage civil plane oh yeah right
here
yeah
you know let me tell you you got it down
so yeah we just got this uh thing we're
gonna get the uh
we're gonna get the little flip going
here listen you're good at this and when
did you start cooking you know when i
was a kid you know i just i loved it i
loved it and i got my son doing the same
thing so he's like uh you know in the
kitchen with me as well he does the
thanksgiving dinner kendall every year
nice the kendall dinner stuff's the bird
the whole thing wow kendall do you do a
lot of cooking as well i do not i
do my best i think i told you i used
some hello fresh and freshly those
so they kind of almost do the meal for
you but i still feel like i'm cooking
well that's a start it's a start it's a
start i'm happy with it
right now okay how's this going it's
going good i just want to make sure we
got enough heat
because i think we get that all the way
up to seven and a half oh my goodness
this induction stuff do you find
cooking on an induction as opposed to
gas is a little bit different well the
gas you can regulate the heat yeah right
and that's the thing is you know this
you're kind of guessing you're waiting
for it and then you go too far too
little this is like
you know but the gas at home
kind of like my gas yeah there you go
but um yeah this is about set i think
everything's all ready do you ever
sprinkle the cheese on top well we can
do you want that after you flip it if a
little bit of cheese is good a lot
better a lot
all right okay what makes it what makes
it french as opposed to so i you know
what i don't know that uh
we just started speaking french in that
day
that was it that's all you need to do
now you're going to pick the charger
because although i think we will do this
one yeah we'll do it after you get on
the plate okay voila is it time to pick
up it is and we're going to just take
and slide this okay
because that's more french crazier yeah
and we have french sea salt and chai
finishing salt
and i'm telling you you're going to love
this
the chives are fresh from nanny bubby's
garden yes all right
so there's a fork right there i think
we've got your let's do it
let's do it as we have a few seconds
left here put the plate right up here
okay just all dig in
awesome have some forks guys
check out nanny bubbies kitchen and
garden on social media i'm going to take
a bite as i say this last part here you
can go to
nannybubby.com i also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment all right let's see this guys
come on let's do this before we go all
right
we'll be right back